[Musique]
sharif
excusez bras je vous ai bouyer
[Musique]
amazon uk ce dernier
je suis désolé alex mais c'est fini qui
va à la chasse perd sa place qui tu as
comme infos là pour faire de la maison
d'un piscine c'est la première fois que
je suis au chômage chutent avoir 50 60
non beaucoup moins battu foetus
sap a de la famille dans le coin mais je
voulais voir ma soeur et ma petite nièce
et goûtu si je suis parent est en outre
alex feignies embauché débile oui c'est
lui alléger encore de voir bondir la
règle à la maison c'est du salut tu
nettoies évoque on peut faire ça
voilà ce que tu vas faire c'est une
victoire on va
elle s'est même pas exemptes 6 tu vas te
trouver une nouvelle fois pas plus
riches et une vieille que de 1,10 à un
tournage tu peux te lancer dans une
aventure trop longue
c'est qui c'est normal mais parfaite et
un grand-papa hirsch et il est mort l'an
dernier
excellente nouvelle si je te disais
clairement savoir tu peux obtenir ce que
tu veux on commence quand leçon numéro
un tout est dans le regard accroche bien
le regard de t'apprends accroche
accroche accroche tu as décroché savoir
ce que tu apprends monfils dernière
leçon du jour ta démarche ouest et fait
ça plus les années passent
plus celle de la fraîcheur
[Musique]
non
c'est de la merde
je m'en viens avec ma foi grandit on a
juste un tout petit tour
depuis l'enfance je suis fasciné par les
langues j'en ai inventé une
tu as inventé tout une langue oui j'ai
créé des histoires des légendes
[Musique]
raconte moi une histoire dans la langue
de ton choix
c'est une histoire qui parle de voyage
deux voyages pour se mettre à l'épreuve
aventure
on devrait former un club une confrérie
nous changeons le monde
grâce au pouvoir de l'art la musique la
poésie et toi attaque m je veux écrire
d'une magie qui dépasse tout ce qu'on a
pu ressentir jusqu'à présent
parce que signifie aimer
et être aimé
c'est la guerre l'angleterre est en
guerre
l'aisance avec laquelle vous saisissez
leur rythme de la langue je dois le
reconnaître monsieur tolkien
je n'ai jamais rien vu de semble
c'est plus qu'une simple amitié
c'est une alliance
invincible
une communauté
bonjour madrid
qu'est-ce qui va pas un archos ce que je
vois mon la part seule idée ça me fait
chier les temps de ma vie dans une pile
de cartons et un tas de sacs plastiques
et les accompli 15 5 et 20 cartons pas
tu sais à quelle date tu dois y être
dans une semaine dans une semaine
tu t'en vas vivre à londres dans sept
jours et je suis pas au courant puisque
rien du tout fm c'est un problème dans
la vie il fasse rien du tout et une
maîtrise de folie céleste et d'une
personne exceptionnelle
c'est le dernier jour dans l'appartement
comme c'est notre dernier soir je veux
un truc de ouf fourneaux voie
professionnelle boucher sans aucun
avenir en chine et ensuite un super
meirieu tu te détends mais tous
demandent à la bonne fille de réaliser
tout espoir
[Musique]
que vous emmèneriez sur une île déserte
quoi durera que deux personnes sur l'eau
donc tu peux choisir qu'une seule
personne
on est obligé de dire la vérité
réac la vérité sincère
ses nuits avec toi ont été les meilleurs
et les pires moments de toute magie
des affaires qui roule devrait pas du
tout changé
même ce qui marche pour le mieux est
obligé d'évoluer souvent tu en penses
[Musique]
deux femmes une fois ce matin jo ça va
attendre
[Musique]
quatorze france via watts
et à paris
[Musique]
skype hunter est une unité secrète elle
a été créée pour renforcer la puissance
de notre armée
ces éléments font partie de l'élite vous
ferez face aux missions les plus
dangereuses et aux défis les plus
improbables y compris la mort
c'est une guerre devait éclater de bras
est ce que vous seriez prêt à le faire
celui qu'ils appellent le prêtre quand
ils ont demandé la libération et le chef
de l'organisation faisceau lumineux
il est responsable de nombreuses
attaques terroristes rabat et legs
notre peuple pourrait vraiment souffrir
si on acceptait pas de se battre pour
lui j'effectuerai cette mission
n'oubliez jamais cédé au niveau traquer
qu'il ne faut pas tomber entre leurs
mains
qui c'est complet par la noirceur ne
verront jamais la vraie lumière pauvre
et je le plains
chaque seconde passée au sol est une
perte de temps précieux
non
ce rêve de gamin d'être pro d'aller à
l'entraînement tous les matins de vivre
du foot c'était mon rêve
il y avait une aisance technique qui
étaient ces de ce genre d'aisance
technique qui s'apprend pas causé assez
de l'inrs et c'est de là qu'ils s'y du
talent antoine ils vont le voyez tous
les deux trois mois c'était compliqué
1,14 à la real sociedad
je tiens à le remercier des je t'aime ça
déjà pour mon père dit je t'aime à moi
tout seul si compliqué mais là devant 2
des milliers de personnes encore encore
plus et griezmann
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'estrie s y est il préférable
champion du monde donc il faut tout
donner
[Applaudissements]
arrivé par hasard
[Musique]
qu'il arrive et tranquille humble il a
gagné ses galons
messi au real c'est écrit sinon les
ticos et 5 besoin la sultane de soi pour
le collectif
le pouvoir ça se donne pas
ça se prend
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]